booking the last meeting of the council
United committee demon says she comes to
the letter against the Morgan and
councilor Witham
none were received
latest
Thanks James
thanks very much any questions councilor
Carter
yes thank you
thank you um
it's my recollection from previous
reports that historical and recent
history Trafford has been behind on
responses within the allowed time on
fois
I ask is there a Improvement in that and
is there a plan plan if not so to
improve I'll come back with a second
question
[Music]
thank you and second query was around
completion of mandatory training moving
up from 83 to 87 completion
I'm assuming if it's mandatory the
target's a hundred uh is there a
and a pretty sorry and I presume
the date to get that done has passed and
you're reporting 87 is where we got to
on time is that correct
um the target is set at 95 percent
I think that's to take a character of
that within any trade for regime people
will have a
obviously 100 would be the uh worthwhile
uh best scoring Department across the
council at the moment is scoring 98
below
um
so you're anticipating or aiming for 95
by the end of the year yeah thank you
any further questions anybody
because
thank you um just following on from what
council cast has just said there about
uh Freedom of Information and just for
my own context what are the driving
factors behind those historical problems
could you give us a bit more information
on on that
foreign
okay thanks anybody else
okay well that's uh what you've got to
work away with that Mark someone and
jebs so can we agree the recommendation
which I think is just that we note
just consider the report really
uh
oh do you want another question sorry
may I
sorry just on on
what kind of um a comment in a question
on
[Music]
um
risk four and secondary school places I
can see there's a tremendous amount of
intelligent cooperative and creative
work being done to generate additional
capacity in particularly south of the
river
um
but with the existing footprint of
schools and school premises I suspect
we're getting close to
the maximum of what we can squeeze out
of that fixed resource I guess
another solution is to build another
school which is entirely out of the
decision-making of the authority and is
a national decision are there actions
being taken and are there additional
actions that could be considered
to try to move the national decision
makers to increase capacity south of the
river thanks
I know I know from uh I was probably
going back a year or two on this risk
that that query was raised and I know
talked about the time I'm not aware any
specific developments on that it's
something I'd have to take with
education take back to them to ask them
the position on that
you know
okay
anything else no thank you going pass on
to item six and the anti-fraud and
Corruption strategy which is again mark
okay thanks chair
um so this document and the report is
basically um a refreshed uh
strategy document it's been a few years
since since that had been last reviewed
by the committee
um
so basically audits work with a number
of services including the counter fraud
team and also legal services including
James here as well to to update and
refresh the strategy
um so the report sets out
um like the overall strategy
encompassing
um the the framework supporting
anti-fraud as well as uh the the fraud
corruption policy and response plan but
we've also included the report the
anti-month money laundering policy
because that have been subject to review
and update in the last year
um so starting on page 10 with the
strategy that sets out the council's
overall approach
um and and you see it refers to details
of the corporate framework uh various
policies and guidance supporting it
um and then the the fraud and Corruption
policy starting on page 17 sets out
expected standards uh required the role
of respective Services
um in in addressing fraud and Corruption
risks
and then in the report on page 29
there's a fraud response plan and that
highlights arrangements for reporting
fraud and and contact details to enable
uh for for investigators
um so the documents have all been
refreshed to reflect updated National
guidance was the likes of uh sit first
managing uh the risk of Fraud and also
fighting fraud locally document for
local government so we've we've updated
in light of that and also things like
contact details service details the
corporate priorities so just give them
the document a general refresh
um
it does notes in the strategy that there
are a number of policies and guidance
supporting this so things like
prosecution policies uh codes of
conducts
um so these are all not these aren't all
included in the document the money
laundering one is on the basis that has
been reviewed and updated this year and
expected that there will be a number of
other
um documents subject to review during
your year and a known particular likes
of around prosecution and Recovery
processes and our legal will will be
will be involved in looking at that
um
it's expected in terms of 23 24 that the
fraud team will um and you'll you'll get
an update from David Wright and in a few
months time on the work of the fraud
team over the last year but that they'll
be involved in it also helping raise
awareness around the strategy
um and also they'll they'll give give
the committee an update on on work done
over the last year
um so we're just asking the committee if
they could approve the the refreshed uh
anti-form corruption strategy and and
supporting guidance
thanks Mark to Legal one to say anything
yes
it's probably appropriate to note that
if fraud has been dealt with by way of
criminal proceedings at the moment there
is an extraordinary delay in terms of
our prosecution work we have not had
summons as authorized and listed by the
magistrates Court since August and the
next date that we have for first
hearings is the 19th of May that is due
to problems that greater Manchester
magistrates courts has in terms of
shortage of Staff they admit they're in
crisis they have a recruitment program
that is ongoing they are also being
beset at the moment by something called
operation Safeguard which is the housing
of prisoners in police stations and
courtrooms because they lack a prison
cells at the moment with the
consequences that prisoners are coming
late which is mainly that the available
number of Court hearings are not
operating efficiently the net result is
they are reducing the number of Court
hearings they run per week from a little
over 20 to 13 the knock-on effect of
that is of course that local Authority
work has not had the priority that it
should have done there was a court user
group meeting last week where we are
assured and there's a new schedule of
Court hearings going on that local
Authority work will now be given uh
greater priority in the list but as I
said that's not starting till uh May and
the knock-on of that is in terms of
fraud recovery is that if you were
looking to recover the proceeds of fraud
through criminal proceedings and you
started today by the time a serious case
got to the Crown Court with all the
delays you're probably looking two years
down the line before you would get to a
point where confiscation proceedings
could begin and that of course gives a
fraudster a a a window of opportunity in
which just to uh to spend their games so
one of the things that we would like to
look at is a recovery process procedure
that is agile and makes use of both
civil and criminal proceedings on things
like freezing orders so that going
forward there are there are all the
available tools in the Box to enable the
maximum amount of money to be recovered
from anybody who chooses to defraud the
council
foreign
thank you and really interested in that
about looking for a more Nimble and
Fleet footage things in the um
the the
current backlog Co-op procedure I'm kind
of intrigued how do we know where the
traffic's good
anti-fraud and anti-corruption is having
loads and loads of detected cases a
benchmark of how good we are or is
having very few cases
a good outcome because people know they
can't get away with it in my defense
days when I have represented defendants
I've always taken the view that it's
very rare that you uh that the
intelligent criminal is ever caught
because they are the ones that get away
with it because they're good at it
um I don't think many people actually
fall into that category
um the the council is fortunate because
it it runs a
very sophisticated set of auditing
functions which are Adept at detecting
flaws and
um in my time here I've seen quite a few
that have been detected and they they
have come to light uh through diligence
and Reporting and appropriate responses
by investigating officers there is
always room for improvement
um it's very difficult to know what you
don't know I would say but the the the
the the the refresh policy does seem to
strengthen in so far as possible uh
everything that should be done about it
and of course we have just come out of a
period of time when there has been a an
opportunity for fraud because of the
loans that the loans and grants at the
council was administering I am aware
that quite a number of those have been
detected they have yet to go through the
system
thank you thanks James it's uh
interesting about the courts there yes
yeah okay any more questions
no thanks very much so we're going to
item 70 audit progress reports this is
Karen from mattas
foreign
the first one that came out the main
pack or is it yeah okay thanks
thanks chair I'll I'll talk through this
very briefly really because
um it is actually a relatively short
report I was 21 22 Financial year audit
is ongoing
um you will be aware I think that we
talked at the last meeting about Our
intention being to complete all of the
work by the end of March and we are
still more or less on track to do that
um the reason that I say more or less on
track is that as always with uh with
audits some of the things are outside of
the control of your Finance team and us
we are waiting for
um bits of responses from from other
people
um across the council but generally
speaking we have made some really good
progress and I don't anticipate a
problem being substantially complete by
the end of the month
um I think probably fair to say that
there isn't anything coming out of the
order at this stage that you as a
committee need to be concerned about so
um you know it is it is all progress as
normal alongside completing the 21 22
audit we have also started our planning
for 20 to 23 and we've done that because
as soon as we close 21 22 we'll then
roll forward into 22-23 with some hope I
think of of getting back onto a more
normal timetable over the coming
um six to nine months
um I think the the second part of this
report is the uh things that we bring to
your attention because they are relevant
to you in terms of your wider governance
function
there's nothing specific in there that I
think you need to be concerned about or
or not
um what I would say though is that there
are a couple of interesting reads on
there
um one of them is the first one that we
reference which is the super guide to
inside sourcing software authorities at
locking spring Services back in-house
that have previously been run by
independent contractors there's some
helpful tips and hints I think really
for how to make sure to show that
process goes well and I'm bringing it to
your attention because it's an easy read
and some of those points might be
helpful
um if the council has decisions to make
over the coming couple of years
um and then the other one is the
National Audit office report on
education recovery in schools and I
mentioned that just because again it's a
well-written report it's a good read and
it probably gives members um some areas
to to think about and focus on really
and as part of your wider role in in the
council not necessarily as part of this
committee that's really all I was going
to say about the report but I'm happy to
take any questions on the work we're
doing in the progress we're making
any questions
I'd hope for you to think you'd come
along and didn't have any questions
um
what I I think I'm picking up as you're
a bit behind schedule compared to where
we would normally be and if that if
that's correct are you confident that
we'll catch up or are we going to
snowball and be more behind more behind
in future years
so to answer the question are we a bit
behind
um not as far behind as you would think
actually because there are a lot of
orders in fact probably most audits in
Greater Manchester not signed off for 21
22 because of the technical issue on
infrastructure
um that we've been talking through for
some time so
um the the position on infrastructure is
that
um
the statutory override the government
brought forward to address the concerns
uh was enacted on Christmas Day
um the guidance from sit for came out in
the middle of January and your team have
been working through
um reflecting that guidance in your
account meanwhile we've been carrying on
with the rest of the audit we agreed
with um Graham and his team some months
ago that we would
um not come in and do try and do lots of
detailed audit work at the period that
they were trying to do work on the
budget to help you with budget setting
process and make sure you've got all of
that on time so some of the delay is
um a function of of not starting on time
because we we had some slippage but some
of it is kind of planned we're going to
come back when it works for both sides
um I'm not since this person a problem
being finished by the end of the month
as long as we get back the information
that we're we're requesting we are
um the reason I'm probably sending more
hesitant than I am is we've had a slight
uptick this week in the number of people
that have reported they've tested
positive for kovid and I'm just a little
bit concerned that I may have lost one
or two people from the team
um over the last day or two but um they
are working hard we are making progress
I think we had an update meeting
um with your colleagues this week just
to clarify exactly what so it's done is
still around property plant equipment
valuations so that that information can
be chased up but I don't anticipate any
significant issues
true
thank you any more questions
no okay thanks very much Karen thank you
pass on to item eight budget monitoring
reports period 10. uh are you going to
do that my cause
grammar
okay yeah
foreign
thank you
thanks Graham thanks for Carter
thanks Chad
and
thanks Graham headlining that is
absolutely fantastic coming back four
and a half million quid
um I think given that the materiality of
the and reading the note minimum Revenue
position
provision revision
are you able to give
an explanation of what that actually
means
um in a sufficiently simple way so that
we'll hopefully get it first time and
is it a something that affects this
financial year only or
is it an annual gift
I'll try to explain it as simply as I
can
happy to talk afterwards or to anybody
who wants any further explanation but
MRP
is
the terminology that we use
for the monies that we set aside to
repay the debt that we take on as an
authority to pay for things like the
refurbishment to the town hall
back in 2012 13. this costs 25 million
pounds of refurbish we took on a lawn to
pay for that because we knew there was
long-term benefit so
Street lighting Investments
Trafford Town Hall a lot of the
Investments through the asset strategy
mean that we have to borrow money to
fund those Investments what the MRP is
is the statutory requirement we've got
as an authority to set usad monies every
year such that when that debt matures
we've got enough money in the bank to
pay it back
um
just to explain what we do when we take
out loans we take out loans from the
public works loans board and we do that
on a what we call on a maturity loan
basis so what that means is
it might be a 25-year loan like a
mortgage but we pay that back in full at
year 25.
but what we must do through the minimum
Revenue provision is set aside an amount
each and every year such that at the end
of that period with enough in the bank
to repay it and I think just the thing
to just
to note there is that the loans that we
ever take out for capital investment are
always done
recognizing the length of the life and
the benefit we will get from the assets
we've created so if you take the town
hall we would have assessed a useful
life on that when we did it we took a
loan out for an appropriate period and
we're now saving up through MRP to pay
that back and what what what the the
options we've got around the MRP is
we must set aside the amount to repay
the Lord over the 25 years or whatever
that period is
either on a straight line basis saw an
equal amount every year or what we've
moved to and what they call an annuity
basis which is similar to what happens
on a repayment style mortgage so you re
your principal repayments start law and
increase all the time
so that's the approach that we're now
taking around our minimum Revenue
provision
I hope that was clear
ish yes
um yeah
[Music]
so what it raises a few questions so
what prompted the change why didn't we
do it this way around when we started
out
and do what do most other authorities go
down the annuity basis route thanks
I think some do
some do
um
I think what problem to the change was
we've not really reviewed our MRP policy
for probably about seven or eight years
um I think what we're seeing now is that
the accident we get benefits from the
assets that we create
to a large extent those benefits will
increase over time and I look at some of
the Investments through the asset
strategy so we've invested in property
um
and those properties generate income
those income streams increase all the
time as we get rent reviews and things
like that in
so what we're doing is
as we get increasing benefits from those
assets we're trying to map the MRP to
align to those benefits
um and it's something we'll keep under
review to make sure it's still an
appropriate policy going forward
it may Independence
there is that sorry chair I'm sorry
okay
should you go first
thank you and the capital program has
been revised down by 13. million pounds
because of the reprofiling of some major
schemes like the mayor's challenge fund
Carrington Carrington relief Road and
the disabled facilities Grant can you
can you explain a bit does that mean
delaying the programs what does
reprofiling mean please
when we set the capital program we might
have schemes that are delivered over a
number of years
[Music]
um Capital programs by definition
sometimes are quite difficult to get the
profile in exactly right
um and what we do is we Flex that budget
to reflect how we think we're delivering
these projects
what we're totally mindful of and I've
never seen it yet is that whilst we do
do that flexing we don't lose resources
so with no reflection on schemes that we
can move the resources so it's just a
question of timing really
but Ross okay okay
you know when we take loan so it means
that we want we are not doing any
capital investment just in case that's
you just mentioned that we have spent
money on the on the building for the
Improvement of the console buildings so
Wi-Fi taking a loan so is not risk
involved because it is not investment
then we are taking loan and spending on
the fixed asset and and it is not
investment anyway so
so is it a risk involved when you're
taking a loan
I think what we've got to be mindful of
is we operate within something called
the Prudential code okay so we the first
first things first is we will only
invest and take loans for things that
will give us a long-term benefit right
so we know that our occupation of the
town hall and the improvements around
the town hall will have a long-term
benefit
and then that's that's a ruling around
taking loans so
it's not just investment activity it's
things on our on our
and he said what the fixed assets of the
authorities as long as we spend it on
those and enhancing the fixed assets
that we've got through that expenditure
that's perfectly
um suitable for borrowing
okay okay thank you
thanks anybody anybody else
no thanks Graham thank you for that
so item uh um item nine which is another
one of the ones were sent to us by email
is the annual governance
statement approach timetable let's mark
you again I think okay
so the the report sets out the the
approach and the timetable for the 22 3
agassiano governance statement
um I'm presenting the report on behalf
of the director of legal and governance
uh who legal and governance uh work on
coordinating uh collating the statement
um and
someone from that direction will come to
probably the next meeting to provide you
with a draft version of the document
it's a requirement to be produced as
part of the accounts and audit
regulations and it accompanies the
council's annual accounts
um and the regulations require that each
year we review the effectiveness of
governance and controls and reports on
that in the in the annual governance
statement so the report gives some
background in terms of the the national
guidance and framework that are provided
by sip for inputting the statements
together
um is a document that a quite a big team
effort across the council lots of
services uh provide input to it
um the document does contain so the
previous year one contains significant
governance issues and in in this year's
statement that will report on any
progress against them and also outline
any any issues going forward
um and as ever the committee will have
the opportunity when when the document
gets to a draft stage to to comment on
it before it gets before it gets
finalized
um
you see the the last page of the
documents on the on the final fifth page
um sets out the timetable
um and ultimately the aim being to
finalize the document by by the end of
September in line with the the accounts
timetable
um so the committee is just asked to
note the note the approach and that will
be get receiving copy the draft for
future review
okay thanks very much any questions
Oh Come to Carter if you're slipping
okay thanks very much thanks Mark but we
get plenty of opportunities or who is on
the committee next year opportunities oh
yeah
okay here we go on to item 10 the audit
and Assurance service into an audit
operations I'll See You Again Mark I
think thank you so the the report sets
out internal audit plan for for 23 4.
um that's recently been shared and
agreed by CLC
um and we've had engagement with each of
the the council's corporate directors to
agree the various pieces of work within
the plan
um the audit Works undertaking in
accordance with our internal audit
Charter and strategy
um which sets out the role of audits and
and the approach we take to our work
those documents are in the appendices
the the they're unchanged from from the
previous year there for there for
information
um
in terms of the plan for this year
um page 67
um section three uh covers some of the
areas a bit more detail later in the
port in terms of factors that take into
account in producing the plan
um and also resources that we have uh to
undertake it
um section 3.16 refers to the resources
in terms of our internal audit Staffing
budget and we've also got some budget to
to purchase this external expertise so
we're continuing to use Salford in turn
Lord it to help us with with aspects of
the it audit work
um section four then of the report talks
about monitoring of that plan through
the year so we'll continue through the
23-4 year to to give updates
um at each of the committee meetings
with progress against the plan
um so in terms of the what's in it
section five sets out the the range of
of coverage in in the in the plan
um and Talking briefly in terms of
themes within it
um in section 5.2 refers to the
financial systems audits so there are a
number of reviews in there
um there's also liaison with external
audit with that and they would get
copies of all our final audit reports
um and reviews include uh around some of
the adults and and children's systems
the social care payments
um and a number of other uh audience of
Key Systems
um there was work we did this year on
council tax will follow up on that so
you'll see a listing there of several
Financial systems in the plan
um also in terms of supporting certain
statutory uh elements of our work
there's the annual governance statement
as I've mentioned before we'll have some
input to to reviewing that and also
around strategic risk register we're
building in a number of audits that are
that are looking at uh
that area includes the school places
risk for example as an audit later in
the year looking at the admissions
process
um
anti-fraud work will continue to link in
with the other services across the
council will report on our national and
fraud initiative work that we that we
help coordinate and that updates will
come to the committee on that
um continuing to work with star and
we've got a number of reviews including
in the plan with star some of those are
going to be led by other councils and in
those sort of cases we still share our
work because a lot of the time the
findings will apply across the board
um and also within procurement contracts
block of the plan we'll look at another
areas likes of the joint ventures we've
done some work recently done some work
around Waste Services so we'll follow up
on the audit around that also the joint
ventures included in the plan
um there are some areas we're still
developing
um around I.T and information governance
you can see from from uh the update we
have before on information governance
we're looking at developments over the
coming months and and will agree
suitable audit work uh on the back of
that in the coming months
um in terms of I.T there's initial piece
of work we've agreed uh looking at the
I.T service management application which
called Fresh service and that's used to
help support the I.T service desk in in
managing requests and managing the
service
um
a block of time around schools as well
to give Insurance around controls in
schools and and looking at their
adherence to the school's financial
value standard
um and you see in section 5.9 there's
there's a whole host of different audits
in there really to help reflect good
coverage across the council it's
corporate priorities some of the some of
the Strategic risks to see there's a
number of reviews across adults
children's and place
um there are quite a few reviews from
the 21-2 plan that we did we agreed we
would start roundabout now so March time
so there are a number of reviews just
starting or in progress that will report
in quarter one example of that being the
latter States audit that we audited last
year
um and gave a limited Assurance for and
we're currently doing a follow-up to to
review all the improvements that that
have been made in that area saw a report
on that in quarter one
um there's a bit of an unknown in the
plan as time set aside for reviewing
Grant claims and data quality
um those sort of tasks are typically
given to us during the year and we don't
always know in advance how much work
there will be around that
um we know typically disabled facilities
grant that will be expected to undertake
checks of but other areas or become
known as the year goes on
um and we'll also keep a block of time
for any ad hoc service advice and and
any new new issues that that come up
during the year
um will include time in the plan to
follow up 22 uh three work uh another
example of that there was one of the
school reviews where there was a limited
level of assurance so we'll put in some
time to go and revisit revisit that
um we keep some contingency in the plan
as well to to cover any unexpected
issues or shortages
um and try and keep the keep it flexible
it's not sat in stone in the sense that
if other priorities come up that would
we'd agree in liaison with with CLT and
also report here you know if we did any
significant changes to what we would
said we were going to do
um so summing all that up in appendix
one starting on page 82 there's a table
there showing the various categories of
work and so indicative days that we we
plan to spend
uh and also in appendix to you'll see on
page 88 are various opinion levels for
audits for each audit report we issue
the the four different opinion levels
ranging from the substantial good level
Assurance through to low or no Assurance
um and it's those lower areas where we
typically spend more time following up
um and as mentioned earlier the charter
and the strategy documents are there for
information as well so I'll I'll
continue to you know report some
progress against that plan so there'll
be a quarter One update that will come
to the committee
um later in the year
I'm happy to take any questions on
that's counselor
yeah we'll continue to meet with the
various Partners through the year
yes
[Music]
just the two
um
at other meetings we receive reports
that show here is the plan of the plan
of savings that
the council has committed to make in
order to balance its budget and some of
them are fully On Target to be
achieved and some are lagging behind is
is audit does the audits work
does the work of the auditing team and
the audit plan include looking at
are those are all of those proposed
savings
legitimate look through checked for
validity and where they are if any are
running behind
what
what was the process that allowed that
decision to be made if it's if it's not
deliverable
where we in terms of those those various
areas we Link in on different audits
around that approach we don't have an
explicit role analyzing every single one
I think other services
probably grain could come in on that as
well we'll get involved in that but we
certainly acknowledge uh in different
for instance homeschool transport audit
we did
um where there's the financing change
program work around that and sort of
encouraging the linkages around that so
but it isn't an explicit role of the
audit to to look at the progress against
an individual it may happen as part of a
piece of work but it's not our
day-to-day role to to monitor that it's
the it's the controls support in the
various service which ultimately should
help them to
reduce the risk of fraud errors and in
effect you hope that that would lead to
savings as well in itself
I can just add to that I think I think
just on delivering a savings program I
think just the process we go through in
setting the budget is that
in terms of time scales we're
considering saving probably from early
summer to October when we present a
draft budget reports
what we're doing over that time period
And in the run-up to Christmas is doing
full business cases for each of those
savings because part of my role is to
sign the budget off for being robust and
if we've not assessed the savings for
being deliverable
um and having that thorough business
case process uh review of the quality
impact assessments and things like that
um we will find it difficult to deliver
I think just what once we've set the
budget what do we do I think
through the bi-monthly monitoring that
we do we're picking up and we're looking
at individual savings plans I think what
I've stressed on for the role of finance
and change this time as well is that
given that the size of the Savings
Program for 234
approaching 12 million pound is quite a
significant one and I think we need that
dual Focus both through the monitoring
that we do as part of the budget and
through finance and change
um it's no good looking at a budget for
24.5 when things might be coming off the
rails for 23 4 so
I've asked that we maintain that dual
focus on achieving the Savings Program
during 203-4
thank you and I completely get the
pressures that officers are under to try
and come up with savings with their
exact approval to meet increasingly
strange circumstances much more detailed
minor question uh second question
um within the program for next year
you've got a look at Outdoor Advertising
Revenue generation within that audit
does that include some sort of
benchmarking to see how does traffic do
compared to other authorities in that
income stream
um the terms of reference for that
currently being put together so that's
the sort of thing that we would
typically cover but yeah that's
something I'll I'll look at with the
with the relevant audits here
okay
any further questions anybody
thanks a lot Graham so we go on to item
11 accounting Concepts and policies and
this is Nikki Royal I'm not sure Nick
have you been to the committee before I
don't remember
uh
oh there we go
um yeah my surname was ryland's I think
when I last came so
um yes I've been married since then so
um but for those that haven't met I'm
Nikki Boyle and the Strategic finance
manager for corporate
um I'll just run through the accounting
policies notes it's quite a long note so
I won't go into too much detail but as I
think would be here all night
um but the accounting
um policies now it just gives details of
the accounting policies and Concepts and
that the council use when we compile the
accounts for 22.23 and the statutory
accounts are prepared in accordance with
the code of practice for local Authority
accounting and for international and
financial reporting standards
the accounts are prepared on a going
concern basis that just means that
um we'll continue in operational
existence for the foreseeable future
the appendix one gives the full details
of the accounting policies
um but the key policies include accruals
of income and expenditure
um IE account for stuff in the year in
which it relates not the year in which
we receive
um the the cash or we make the payment
I'm accounting for non-coin assets this
just covers How would how assets are
classified in the balance sheet
accounting for financial instruments
this covers how Financial assets are
included on the balance sheet
employee benefits and pensions covers
how benefits people driving employment
and post employment and termination
um are accounted for
schools this gives details of the types
of schools and their accounting
transactions and those which were
included in the council's accounts
and group accounts this includes
Trafford Leisure and traffic
um appendix to that covers the changes
for accounting policies for 22.23
there's been very little changes uh for
22 23 and those changes are around where
the technical quality so
not many changes to what how we actually
count for stuff just more clarity
um in the actual code itself
changes issued but not yet adopted the
same one is on here from last year which
is IFRS 16 accounting for leases that's
been pushed back another year again
um it's been pushed back for the last
few years so
um now that has been pushed back to 22
24 sorry 25
and this just relates to how we count
for assets previously these well
currently as well sorry there is a
distinction between operating leases and
um Financial leases
there's no one going to be a distinction
between those
um that it will just be what he says he
and our leases will be accounted for on
the balance sheet
um we currently pulling together a piece
of work on this looking for what leases
the council have and Gathering the
information together to see what impact
this might have on our accounts in 24
25.
the 2223 and audited accounts
um are required to go on deposit for the
31st of May and currently no extension
but there is a
um well there has been a consultation
that ended on the 2nd of March
um which we're unaware of the outcomes
currently but there is potential that
this deadline may be pushed back
I'm
I work at we work in towards the 31st of
May until we know the outcome of that
consultation
and I think Kevin mentioned this briefly
before but infrastructure assets
um a temporary solution has been
announced an amendment to the code has
been made for accounts between April 21
and March 24 2025
we've undertaken a review of the
Amendments and considered the current
accounting policies and
and we consider these to comply the
Amendments we already comply with these
amendments and so we're not proposing
any changes to our accounting policies
um external Auditors are currently being
consulted about this and and what will
um
we'll we'll assess but yeah we're not
we're not currently proposing any
changes to our accounting policies for
infrastructure assets
that is just it I know it's quite a long
report but that's a quick overview and
and it did go through it quite quickly
but um it's requested that the committee
um approves the
in accounting Concepts and policies and
know the changes for the IFRS 16 that's
the accounting policy that's not yet
been adopted and will be adopted in 24
25.
anyone got any questions
any questions
it may well be the same question Council
the consultation ended on the second of
March excuse me that we're still waiting
on the outcome do we have a time scale
on that at all no I I have been looking
for any news on it and having you might
know a bit more but I haven't seen
anything come out yet
I haven't seen anything either nor have
I seen anything that says when they'll
make a decision by one of the issues
underpinning that is that it will
require a statutory instruments come
forward to change it but I think it will
change if I was putting my money on it
um I think it'll go back I think it'll
go back to the 30th of November and the
30th of June so accounts on deposit by
the end of June in order to by the end
of November because I think there is a
recognition that the balance between
speediness and accuracy
um maybe slightly tipped in the wrong
place at the moment with the end of May
deadline and so I think that's what will
happen but obviously it does depend on
on ministers there for that decision
thank you
[Music]
thank you um page 125 in the deck talks
about the Trafford Town Hall collection
it's a series of assets artworks
whatever of some historic and financial
value
is there a similar collection owned by
Trafford at the building known as
alteringham Town Hall
sorry I'm just getting to the page
foreign
myself I know I'm not I'm gonna say I'm
not 100 sure whether
um I wouldn't know for 100 without
checking our assets but
I think we can get back to you
yeah
[Music]
uh I can see there is a there are
intangible assets uh where about
licenses and Microsoft and all those
things I can't see there are tangible
assets because an amount has been fixed
ten thousand uh to to recover because of
Any deposition occurred during the
course of period of time while we are
using yes so
does this amount
increase or decrease every year right
it's just fix
uh in in terms of depreciation is that
yes yes so all assets are depreciated
and they all have the specific
um
useful economic life that we'd
appreciate them over and each asset
category is depreciated
um
using a different method I mean if the
counting policies does go through and
say on what method they are used each
each specific asset so if you if you
I know it is quite big but there's yeah
quite a few different types of assets
it's a long list of tangible listers
intangibility yes and the depreciated
over different methods
um so
yeah I'm
I think Japan I'm not sure I can answer
specific questions
there are different categories but okay
yeah we we do depreciate them over
different useful economic lives and yeah
they're held all right thank you
okay
I just it just came to a mind about the
uh the valuable assets I think all the
the offsets were as a long time ago were
all assembled here if you look in the uh
silver case outside you'll see stuff
from Ultra and so on so I don't I doubt
there's anything
I mean it's a long story to all this so
it was sold off I think right long
before your time Graham so so it was
sold off uh at auctions in London I
think so
I think
I don't know when this category of asset
came onto the bow and she you're
probably talking 10 or 15 years ago and
I know at that time
we got valuations of I think we would
probably
Consolidated a lot at the point where
you refurbished the town hall and I
think we brought it together and valued
it whether we've got anything specific
at altering them I'm not too sure if we
have it's probably part of the overall
valuation we've got both I'll clarify
that
to see if there's anything at altering
because it
deposition is also the port of expenses
when you're making a balance sheet
I'm right
I think just for local authorities
depreciation is
is not a charge to our budget it's it's
just the way we account for the
consumption of our fixed assets when we
consolidate our accounts yes
we depreciate the assets to reflect the
consumption of those assets but it's not
something
um that we put through our management
account so when we're doing the period
monitoring depreciation doesn't feature
as part of that and I think just going
back to the concept of minimum Revenue
provision yes that's really the cost of
that's rather than charging depreciation
to our management accounts we charged as
an authority for minimum Revenue
provision so that's probably the
distinction between us in a private
company yeah
thank you
[Music]
okay thanks very much we're going to
item uh thank you Nikki for that we'll
see you again no doubt uh some uh item
11 and C work programs markets you see
so this obviously the last meeting of
the committee here so the the report
sets out everything that's been covered
um most areas have been covered that we
set out to do uh there are a few that
have obviously been I've been put
forward to the next meeting or two see
around the accounts uh the 21-2 accounts
has been discussed uh there was also an
item around a strategic risk item around
cyber security that was originally on
the plan we're planning to put that
hopefully the next the next meeting
um so there'll be a there'll be an
updated work plan that will come to the
next committee and it'll take into
account also comments made made through
the year on on future items
um there'll also be an annual report
written for the work done this year uh
that the the chair will be able to to
take to council with
okay thanks very much any comments
no thank you and thanks very much with
me
so item 13 is uh urgent business I'm not
aware of any items of urgent business
item 14 exclusion resolution I'm not
aware of any uh confidential matters we
have to exclude our best audience from
so having said all that I think that's
the uh the end of the meeting and then
as Mark said it's the end of the meeting
series of meetings for this year
so